i saw the diamond fight baby
and i want to thank everybody for all
the dms and messages i got
i can't even imagine what dustin got
just
being a friend of dustin's i got um
i got i man i must have got 4 000
messages congratulating me
um on that man's victory and he's a
victory man if you saw the
if you saw the fight
you know he came out with a game plan
which it just it was showed a lot of
evolution of him as a fighter
i thought this is you know there's two
ways that i look at dustin i look at him
as a
as a friend and somebody that i care
about and then i look at him as a
fighter
you know so um you know on the fighting
side
i think a lot of people expected him to
just come out and be
you know captain punchy out there you
know [ __ ] benedict fists out there
you know what i'm saying
[ __ ] larry knuckles out there just
bucking the trend baby you know
and just hoping for the best um
[Music]
but he came out revamped
i mean he would be a vampire but with
the sharp teeth on the bottom you feel
me he came out
revamped and he had a plan
and he executed it man and there was
something about him winning
and i felt this in a lot of people that
were what they were cheering him on that
you just felt hopeful
about stuff in your own life or things
in the world you know you felt like you
know the sun was gonna come up tomorrow
you just felt like that a little
um and i love what his wife said at the
at the end of the fight y'all aren't
gonna
don't doubt my husband again something
like that i just
you know i just
you know they just have never paid him
fare they've never paid him fare
and for him to be there in that hotel
for two weeks
and he's looking out and connor's out
there on that yacht on that bars kind of
owns a damn barge
you know connor's out there just and
i mean i don't know if he can see it
from his hotel window or not but if that
doesn't create some determination in you
um but i didn't doubt him man i was
definitely scared
for him because conor's a lethal man
he's got that freaking shoulder snake
baby that that
freaking arm dog and his arm is a lot
longer than it looks
jesus you know his arm you could row a
boat with his arm
you know he got a long arm and um
yeah it was just amazing man i i it was
just
it just you know i was excited for
dustin as a fighter i was excited for
dustin as a
person as well and about his future and
um yeah it was just man i was just
elated
i was literally swinging from the
rafters
of a bar that we went to to watch it at
like they had some steel beams and i'm
in there just swinging back and forth
like a champ
actually hurt my neck swinging on it
so i've had neck pain and now i just
you know i just have more
um but i just
i mean i thought it was a good fight it
was a quick fight but i thought it was a
good fight
i mean conor was still landing some
blows kev uh
you know dustin was hitting him with
those kicks
i mean it was just a lot going on
man it was but i i was just i was i was
just excited i was excited
i was excited man because i picked the
wrong guy a lot of times in fights and
you know betting on the colts or
different [ __ ] like that
you go to the horse races you lose you
know you lose on you know you better you
know
sixty dollars on freaking you know
donny's enemy to come in third or
whatever
or you know whatever it is starburst
enema all
horses have the weirdest names but
finally to get you know just to get it
right
and i want a thousand dollars from your
boy brandon shopvac
and here was the funniest thing was i
got a text from dustin
after the fight and it said
tell brennan he owes you that tell
brennan
he owes you that money that's what he
said man
ah so i just can't imagine i think also
there was a level of just feeling proud
of uh for dustin you know and feeling
proud for him and
um yeah i think
there was something about
it was like man i can't imagine how
awesome he must feel right now you know
just how
proud of himself he must feel and just
how
just deserving you know
you finally i mean damn his experience
with the ufc seemed like he's the one
he goes up to the atm and he's got to
put in money
and finally it comes out and
you know i think you know i think he's
transcended the sport and
you know i've told him that and um
and i'm i'm excited to see his future
i'm excited to see what he does
inside of the ring and then outside of
the ring um
i think on the fighting side it's
interesting how do you figure out who he
fights next
because
you know if you go for the connor
trilogy that's right there but he just
beat him and it's been five years since
the last one like
you know i agree with dustin that
michael chandler who i love michael
chandler's
uh and i hope to have him back in here
soon and um
but he he should have to fight more guys
i mean i understand dustin's point of
view
you know uh man i felt bad for dan
hooker
i really liked dan hooker he seemed like
a really cool guy
um i also thought the whole way the
fight came together was amazing you know
um conor mcgregor is irish man he's an
irish man i love ireland
you know shout out dublin you feel me
and shout out scotland as well man
you know and scotland has just drunk
ireland
let's be honest huh and um
and i you know what i thought that i
mean you know the whole thing kind of
started if i and i and i may be wrong
but it started as a charitable thing
conor and dustin were going to fight for
charity to raise money for their
charities
and then ufc saw that and got involved
you know um
and and so the whole thing started from
a place of charity
i thought that conor was was you know
he's a businessman now
i mean he's got to wake up the next day
and do business he's got
you know he there's a difference when
you go from being
an athlete to the owner of the gym
you're doing two different things it's
two different brains
and i'm not saying that conor's not
still one of the greatest fighters of
all time
i believe it is i mean i just watched
all of his fights in the past month
um
i remember after i watched all those
fights literally i texted dustin i said
hey man where's you how's your
how's your head man are you how you
feeling you know i was [ __ ] scared
dude i hurt my neck i hurt my neck
watching the fight that's how excited i
was
um but no i thought that kind of was a
class act and i thought that dustin
you know i'm just obviously glad that he
won and
there's just no you know he can't
there's you can't deny him anymore
and i felt his angst after the fight you
could feel his angst you know he's angst
it out
and yeah he just said being there for
two weeks and
you know at a certain point if if uh
dana
whatever the man's name is dana wallace
or whatever i don't know what his name
is but dana
uh if big dan had a white money man if
he doesn't
if you don't treat your employees
well enough at some point then they
don't they're going to lose the desire
to work with you
and i i'm just look i don't know also i
don't know anything
she may be listening to this saying man
theo doesn't know anything
and you'll be and you you would be right
but i i i just
you know you gotta you gotta pay your
employees
you gotta pay them you gotta want them
to ride while you ride
and i think people could say well you
know connor's conor's one that sells the
tickets and this and that and
some of that's fair very fair
you know what connor's done for that
sport is amazing and and i'm new to the
sport i don't know that much
but i think you're in the place now
where you have to where do you you want
to pay the man
you know and i think that you know
who was james j braddock where was he
from
oh he's an american boxer well i think
you got a new james j
braddock man that's what it felt like
the hot sauce boss baby that's
cinderella man himself
uh dustin the diamond poirier and um
and you know we love him here but i was
ecstatic man i was so so
you know i was i i was kind of bummed
for conor i mean you know i don't like
to see the people lose
i want i wish at the end every you know
everybody kind of won
but uh but yeah i watched it here in the
central east man and they all you know
michael channel lives here
and so they were going bankers for him
and his wife came back she went home and
watched it and then came back to the
bar after and she was uh they were all
cheering when she came in it was pretty
cool
um but yeah it was it was just a hopeful
time there was something hopeful about
it
there was something exciting about it
especially at a time when big business
is winning everything it feels like and
the little man has been knocked down
and then you see uh a man like dustin
who's not a little man but you see him
say hey not today not on my watch
um and i'm you know i'm done fanboying
but i was
you know i was just uh i was stoked for
him
the guy's been on quite a journey and he
and he has to prove himself
every time and i think a lot of us can
relate to that journey
of con of just constantly having to
prove ourselves
so man but it was definitely exciting
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering
how could i be so far from my
home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
[Music]